* Sanfte, gezupfte Gitarrenklänge *
Das war das erste Leben
in der Schweiz: im Santa Lucia.
Ich habe beinahe alles gemacht.
Ich habe auch Musik gespielt.
Abwaschen, Servieren, Pizza machen.
Dem Personal Haare schneiden.
Ich habe fast alles gemacht.
* Zarte Gitarrenakkorde *
Es war eine schöne Zeit.
Und ich bin stolz:
Mit dem Abwaschen
habe ich ganz unten angefangen.
* Melancholische Gitarrenmusik *
Das ist der Nachbar, kein Problem.
Das ist der erste Laden.
Hoi, Andi!
Mit dieser Filiale im Zürcher Kreis 5
legte Ghamkin Saleh
vor rund 20 Jahren
den Grundstein für sein Imperium
von günstigen Coiffeursalons.
Das Ziel war einfach ...
... zehn Geschwistern zu helfen,
der Familie, die Mutter allein.
Eine alleinstehende Mutter
mit so vielen Kindern.
Das war das erste Ziel.
Nichts stoppte meinen Gedanken.
* Schleppende Trommel-
und Flötenmusik *
"Persönliche Einladung
zum Primeur am 16. April."
Ich bin eingeladen.
"Grüezi."
Diese Dreharbeiten fanden
noch vor der Corona-Krise statt.
Zu diesem Zeitpunkt
rentiert Ghamkin Salehs Unternehmen
von 14 Coiffeursalons
und zwei Restaurants.
Hast du keine Kapazität,
um privat arbeiten zu können?
* Lachen *
Du bist Elektromonteur.
- Ja.
Keine Zeit?
- M-m.
Gar nicht? Null?
Komm jetzt, Mohammed.
Ghamkin Saleh
ist umtriebig und beharrlich.
Eigenschaften, die für eine
Tellerwäscherkarriere hilfreich sind.
Gut 20-jährig flüchtete der Kurde
allein aus Syrien in die Schweiz,
drei Jahre später
eröffnete er dieses Geschäft.
Es ist normal,
dass es schwierig ist.
Die Sprache, die Kultur,
die Bewilligungen in der Schweiz.
Das war alles nicht einfach.
Aber es ist alles möglich -
wenn man will
und wenn man daran arbeitet.
Dann kann man sich
diesen Wunsch erfüllen.
Sein Antrieb
in der schwierigen Anfangszeit:
irgendwann die Familie
zu sich in die Schweiz holen.
* Sanfte Streicherklänge *
Freunde fand er hier schnell.
Einer ist Andreas Schlegel,
sein erster Kunde.
* Sanfte, gezupfte Streicherklänge *
Du bist reingekommen.
Du wolltest die Haare schneiden.
Du hattest die Einweihungsfeier.
Du wolltest die Haare schneiden,
aber es war noch nicht offen.
Aber dann machte ich es gerne,
du warst mein erster Gast.
Ungefähr. Es ist schon lange her.
Er hat es begründet:
"Ich schneide dir die Haare."
Das stimmt.
- Der erste Kunde bringe Glück.
Wir haben angefangen,
Geschichten auszutauschen.
Und ...
Das hat sich
mit den Jahren vertieft.
Irgendwann fragte er mich,
ob ich ihm etwas übersetzen könnte.
Das habe ich gemacht.
Ich schreibe ... Ich habe für ihn
auf Deutsch geschrieben.
Seine Freundschaften verschaffen
Ghamkin Saleh ein potentes Netzwerk -
unerlässlich für einen
erfolgreichen Multiunternehmer.
Ich bin sehr stolz auf mein Land,
das solche Chancen möglich macht.
Er konnte hier etwas Neues anfangen.
Zu Hause war es für ihn
ja unerträglich.
Er kam hierher
und packte seine Chance.
Das finde ich super.
Wem gehört das Telefon?
Was war die Zeit?
In Syrien gehörte Ghamkin Saleh zur
unterdrückten, kurdischen Minderheit.
* Schuss *
Nach der Matura und Musikschule
gab es keinen anderen Weg
als das Militär.
Der nächste Schritt war das Militär.
Dann musste ich ...
Dann bin ich weg.
Ich wollte nie Militär
für Diktatoren machen.
Er sah keine Möglichkeit, in Syrien
seine Lebensträume zu verwirklichen.
Z.B. Filme ...
Man muss in der Baath-Partei sein
und braucht Vitamin B,
um Film studieren zu können.
Es sind diese Momente,
in denen man nicht in seiner Mutter-
sprache die Schule besuchen kann.
Man kann in der Schule
nicht das studieren, was man kann.
Man ist zwar qualifiziert,
um zu studieren.
Aber man kann nicht studieren,
wenn man nicht zur Partei gehört,
die im Land regiert.
Was macht man dann?
Wenn man die Möglichkeit hat,
gibt es nur eines: abhauen.
* Stimmengewirr *
Tschüss zusammen.
* Brummende Musik *
Den Traum vom Filmstudium
holte er in der Schweiz nach.
Gleichzeitig
eröffnete er dieses Restaurant
und baute sein Coiffeurimperium aus.
Zur Filiale
im multikulturellen Zürcher Kreis 5
kamen im Laufe der Zeit Geschäfte
in der teuren Innenstadt dazu.
* Rhythmische Bassklänge *
Das Wichtigste: Die Grossfamilie
ist mittlerweile wieder vereint.
Fast alle Saleh-Geschwister
leben in der Schweiz
und arbeiten im Unternehmen.
Der jüngste Bruder
führt diese Filiale.
Hey, tschau Paul.
- Ça va?
Ja, ja. Danke.
Das ist der Starbruder,
der schönste Bruder.
Salut.
- Hoi.
Wie heisst du?
- Bershes.
Paul, wie immer?
- Ja.
Nichts Spezielles?
- Nein. Keine Dauerwelle.
Keine Dauerwelle?
- Nein.
Augenbrauen?
Kein Kahlschnitt.
* Ghamkin lacht. *
Mit Regisseur Paul Riniker
verbindet Ghamkin Saleh
die Leidenschaft zum Filmemachen.
Er ist sehr fokussiert.
Im Prinzip möchte er
überhaupt nur noch Filme machen.
Er möchte gar nicht
Unternehmer sein.
Ich habe immer das Gefühl, dass er
damit seine ganze Sippe ernährt.
Das ist sein Ziel.
Aber ich habe nicht das Gefühl,
dass er reich werden möchte.
Ist das so?
100 %.
Die Familie ist sicher eine Stärke
dieser vielen Geschäfte.
Aber sie ist auch eine Schwäche.
Sie bindet dich.
- Sie bindet mich, genau.
Genau.
In den letzten Jahren
vergrösserte Ghamkin Saleh
sein Unternehmen sukzessive.
Für jeden Bruder ein neues Geschäft.
Wenn man jemanden
mit Wille und Mut sieht,
der der ganzen Familie nicht scha-
det, dann lassen wir ihn machen.
Wir geben ihm die Chance,
es zu versuchen.
Wir haben ihm die Chance gegeben.
Und ich glaube, er hat recht:
Es ist gut.
Der Bruder macht wirklich alles.
Super selbstständig.
Bald werden sie mir helfen,
dass ich nur noch Filme machen kann.
Das wäre super. Das wäre
eine kleine Belohnung der Brüder:
"Hey, nicht mehr arbeiten!
Sitzen, nur Filme machen."
Das wäre auch eine Option.
Oder, Paul?
- Ja.
So, mein lieber Paul.
Mit einem eigenen Filmprojekt
beschäftigt sich Ghamkin Saleh
seit zwei Jahren.
Das Haus
seines Freundes Andreas Schlegel
soll im Roadmovie
eine Asylunterkunft darstellen.
Also das Haus entspricht
genau meinen Vorstellungen.
Das ist super. Sehr gut. Alte ...
Altes Schweizer ... so ...
... Traditionshaus.
Sehr schweizerisch.
- Sehr schweizerisch.
So ein Traditionshaus
habe ich mir immer vorgestellt.
Als ich in die Schweiz gekommen bin,
habe ich auch einmal
in so einem Haus gewohnt.
Perfekt.
- Das ist der Haupteingang.
Das ist der Haupteingang?
- Ja.
Wir haben auch einen Seiteneingang.
Den können wir auch nehmen.
Achtung, Kopf!
Okay. Supi!
Da hinten wäre der Aufenthaltsraum.
- Das ist super.
Drei Betten wären super perfekt.
- Ja, das kann man machen.
Eins, zwei, drei.
- Evtl. weniger Pflanzen.
Hier ist die Schlussszene des Films
geplant.
Es ist die Geschichte eines Kurden,
der in die Schweiz reist,
um seinen Sohn
zurück nach Syrien zu holen.
Man sieht die Schwierigkeit
der Immigranten,
die in der Schweiz
oder in ganz Europa leben.
Es ist nicht einfach.
Viele haben ihre Heimat verlassen -
nicht freiwillig.
Viele sind auch freiwillig gegangen.
Sie wollten
ein besseres Leben haben.
Jene, die das bessere Leben haben,
sollen schauen ... wie ist ...
Es ist nicht einfach,
wenn man sein Land verlässt.
Es ist genau wie mit einem Baum,
den man mit seinen Wurzeln
an einem anderen Ort einpflanzt.
Es ist nie mehr wie vorher.
Während seiner Anfangszeit
in der Schweiz
vermisste Ghamkin Saleh
die Familie schmerzlich.
Aus dieser persönlichen Erfahrung
will er andere Syrer von
einer überstürzten Flucht abhalten.
Emotional gesehen
fehlt mir selbst nicht viel.
Okay, jetzt ist die ganze Familie
da, das muss man auch sagen.
Du hast deine Heimat
ein bisschen hierhergebracht.- Ja.
Der Unternehmer fühlt sich auch
dank Freunden wie Andreas Schlegel
in der Schweiz zu Hause.
Dieser unterstützt ihn bis heute
bei sprachlichen Belangen,
z.B. der deutschen Untertitelung
des Films.
Sie selbst ...
- Sie sagen, sie sind ... äh ...
Ghamkin Saleh beabsichtigt,
das Roadmovie in einem alternativen
Zürcher Kino vorzuführen.
Die Szenen in Syrien
wurden bereits gedreht.
Mit einer Schweizer Filmcrew
reiste er extra in sein Geburtsland.
Ich habe beinahe ... wie sagt man?
... mit sämtlichen Karten gespielt,
um den Film fertig zu machen.
Ja, und dann hoffe ich,
dass wir das schaffen.
Mit allen Karten:
energiemässig, finanziell.
Alles, alles.
Energie, Finanzen.
Ich habe alles riskiert.
* Schleppende Gitarrenklänge *
Auch auf Geschäftsebene
hat Ghamkin Saleh Appetit auf mehr.
Im zürcherischen Dietikon ist
die erste Saleh-Konditorei geplant.
Mit seinem Architekten
klärt der Unternehmer
die letzten Details für den Umbau.
Wir warten seit fast einem Jahr.
-Ja, genau.
Wir haben langsam die Hoffnung
verloren, ob es geht oder nicht.
Es geht.
Was ich mit den Baubehörden
abgeklärt habe, ist klar.
Ihr habt eine Bewilligung.
Es gibt nur noch kleinere Auflagen,
die erfüll werden müssen.
Seit Jahren
wächst das Saleh-Unternehmen,
obwohl der Gründer stets betont,
dass er am liebsten
nur Filme machen würde.
Was treibt ihn an?
Ist es auch die Freude am Geld,
dass Sie finanziell
erfolgreich werden möchten?
Nein, auf keinen Fall. Nein.
Das war nie das Ziel
in meinem Leben.
Ich habe Freude, wenn ich sehe,
dass andere Freude haben,
dass sie Arbeit haben, dass ich
gratis bei ihnen essen kann.
Ich kann meine Freunde einladen und
vielleicht noch einen Film machen.
Ich lade Leute hier ein,
das ist unsere Bäckerei.
Unsere, nicht meine. Immer unsere.
Dann bin ich sehr stolz.
Ob ich Geld mache oder nicht -
Hauptsache es sind keine
roten Zahlen, dann ist es gut.
Bruder Miguel ist bereits
für das benachbarte Coiffeurgeschäft
verantwortlich.
Er wird auch selbstständig
die Konditorei führen.
Bei wichtigen Entscheidungen
ist jedoch Ghamkin Saleh tonangebend.
Es entspricht
nicht unbedingt der Tradition,
dass ich komme
und alle bereitstehen.
Das haben wir nicht gelernt,
aber Respekt ist schon da.
Vielleicht sieht man diesen Respekt
nicht immer, aber es gibt ihn.
Wir sind einfach Freunde.
Für seine jüngeren Brüder
ist er Chef,
Freund und auch
ein bisschen Vaterfigur.
Ist es auch
eine grosse Verantwortung?
Sie unterstützen eine grosse Familie.
Ja, die Belastung
ist wirklich gross
und es ist
eine grosse Verantwortung.
Er hat einen starken Rücken.
Er hilft.
Helfen und geben -
dann kommt es von alleine.
Er hat ein gutes Herz, das ist so.
* Eindringliche Gitarrenklänge *
Im Zürcher Vorort Schlieren
lebt Ghamkin Saleh
mit seiner Frau
und den beiden Töchtern.
Hallo.
* Es spricht kurdisch. *
Machen wir zusammen Pause.
Ja, okay.
* Die Frau hustet. *
* Er spricht polnisch. *
Kurdisch.
- Kurdisch gekocht, nicht polnisch.
Es ist ein dreisprachiger Haushalt,
denn Katarzyna Saleh
stammt ursprünglich aus Polen.
Mmh!
* Er spricht kurdisch. *
Mami helfen.
* Aufmunterndes Klatschen *
Helfen, helfen, helfen.
Ich muss auch zu Hause Chef spielen.
Zum Abendessen hat die Familie
Besuch von einem Nachbarsmädchen.
Sarah, du trägst
schöne moderne Socken.
* Lachen *
Sarah, sind das Socken
aus Mazedonien?
* Lachen *
Und einmal Nike und einmal Buma.
Buma!
Oder was? Nicht Buma?
Puma!
- Puma. Sorry, gell!
Das ist Crvena.
Aha, ja, ja.
(Katarzyna) Genau.
Das Ehepaar lernte sich
vor bald 20 Jahren kennen,
als die gebürtige Polin in
der Schweiz eine Freundin besuchte.
Er war vor seinem Geschäft
in der Josefstrasse am Telefonieren
und er schaute zu uns.
Nachher fragte er,
ob wir am Abend etwas trinken gehen.
Ich sagte:
"Okay, das können wir machen."
"Aber ich komme nicht allein,
ich nehme die Kollegin mit."
Und so haben wir uns langsam,
langsam kennengelernt.
Du hast etwas
sehr Wichtiges vergessen.
(Mädchen) Augen.
- Ja.
Was?
- Oczy.
Und er hat gesagt,
ich hätte schöne Augen.
Und ich habe gesagt: "Ich weiss!"
Bei den Salehs herrscht
eine traditionelle Rollenverteilung.
Die Ehefrau des Unternehmers
kümmert sich um Haus und Familie.
Sie ist super.
Sie mischt sich nicht viel ein.
Sie unterstützt mich.
Mit all ihren Kräften -
so gut sie kann.
Es ist sehr wichtig,
dass man keinen Druck hat.
Sie hält ihrem Mann den Rücken frei,
kocht kurdisch
und spricht sogar
seine Muttersprache.
Am Anfang war es
auch mit der Sprache schwierig.
Weil, ähm ...
Wir waren viel
mit seiner Familie zusammen,
und ich konnte nicht verstehen,
was sie sagen.
Ein bisschen ...
Zu viel auf einmal.
Alle sprechen eine andere Sprache,
und man ist allein.
- Ja.
Ich habe mich schon allein gefühlt.
- Okay.
Aber jetzt ist es gut.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
* Stimmengewirr im Hintergrund *
* Eindringliche Klaviermusik *
Die Bestellnummer musst du sagen.
Sie haben einen Menüsalat.
Hajati, hast du beide Hände ...
oder nur eine?
Vielleicht nimmst du ein Tuch
oder irgendetwas.
Gut?
Im Mai treffen wir
Ghamkin Saleh wieder.
Attenzione.
Musst du Handschuhe tragen?
- Ja, sie sagten ...
Ist das Vorschrift?
- Nein, nein, aber es ist besser.
Es ist die Wiedereröffnung seines
Restaurants in Zürich Wipkingen
nach einer mehrwöchigen
Corona-bedingten Schliessung.
Administrativ
war es ein grosser Stress:
den Kredit beantragen,
die Kurzarbeit, das Personal.
Ich dachte viel darüber nach,
wie es weitergeht - mit der Miete.
Es gibt keine einzige Verwaltung
oder keinen Hausbesitzer, der sagt:
"Hey, bezahl die Hälfte!"
oder "Bezahl gar nichts!"
oder "Bezahl ein bisschen!"
Alle wollen ihre Miete.
Ein gesetzlich verankerter
Mietererlass für Geschäftsinhaber
ist zu diesem Zeitpunkt
in weiter Ferne.
Die Mietkosten aller Saleh-Betriebe
betragen über 100'000 Fr. monatlich.
Nun fehlen dem Unternehmer aus
der Zeit des Lockdowns die Einnahmen.
Er hat Zweifel, dass alle
seine Betriebe überleben werden.
Also, emotional gesehen
hoffe ich es schon, ja.
Aber praktisch gesehen -
ich glaube nicht.
Ich glaube, Geschäfte
mit einer sehr hohen Miete ...
Man muss mit dem Besitzer
und den Verwaltungen abmachen,
dass sie die Miete reduzieren,
oder wir müssen einfach abgeben,
weil wir es uns
nicht leisten können.
Steht das momentan im Raum?
- Ja, ja.
* Schwermütige Klaviermusik *
Wegen der Corona-Krise
musste Ghamkin Saleh
seine
finanziellen Reserven anzapfen.
Geld, welches
für seinen Film vorgesehen war.
Mind. 50'000 Fr.
würde er für die Fertigstellung
seines Low-Budget-Projekts benötigen.
Ich weiss eigentlich nicht ...
Es ist sehr schwierig.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen,
dass ich meinen Film wegen fehlender
Finanzierung nicht machen kann.
Das wäre Horror.
Weil, äh ...
Mein Wunsch und mein Traum
war es immer, Filme zu machen.
Das war ein weiteres Ziel.
Ich dachte, ich würde das erreichen
und ich kann Filme machen -
sogar auf meine Kosten.
Und jetzt ist es wegen
der Finanzierung wirklich schwierig.
Ich will nicht
mit diesem Gefühl leben.
* Schwermütige Klaviermusik *
Es fehlt noch der europäische Teil.
Es ist ein Roadmovie
über einen Menschen,
der seinen Sohn
in ganz Europa sucht.
Darum geht es im Film.
Eine andere Baustelle
im Leben des Unternehmers:
das Konditorei-Projekt in Dietikon.
Seit über zwei Jahren
steht das Lokal mittlerweile leer.
Ohne Corona-Lockdown wäre es
seit mehreren Wochen in Betrieb.
Nun hoffen Ghamkin Saleh
und seine Brüder,
das Geschäft
Ende Sommer eröffnen zu können.
Es ist wirklich
eine belastende Zeit.
Wir haben etwas gebaut, das jetzt
ein bisschen in Gefahr ist -
wie alle Geschäfte.
Aber wenn ich sie sehe -
dann schaffen wir es.
Ja, wir halten wirklich
ganz fest zusammen.
Der Zusammenhalt - in der Krise
erst recht ein Rettungsanker.
* Kurdisch *
* Sie reden gleichzeitig. *
Es heisst Familie Saleh.
Einer für den anderen.
* Treibende Gitarrenklänge *
Ich kann mit dem Minimum leben.
Eine 2-Zimmerwohnung
anstelle einer 4-Zimmerwohnung,
ein kleines Auto anstelle eines
grossen Autos oder mit einem Töff.
Das ist überhaupt kein Problem.
Die einzige Sorge: Wir sind alle
auf einem Schiff, die ganze Familie.
Aber sonst ...
Ich bin mit 1'000 $
in die Schweiz gekommen.
Ich kann auch mit 1'000 $
die Schweiz verlassen.
Überhaupt kein Problem.
* Die Musik
übertönt das Gesprochene. *
* Zarte, perlende Gitarrenklänge *
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Andrea Werlen - 2020